there seemed to be rushing around all
the time having to do things and got a
lot of patience to cope with June is
Keen to go home she's been in hospital
for three weeks after a fall but you
knows things have changed and her sons
May no longer be able to care for her
the two boys come in and help me they
have been but whether they'll be able to
cope with
because I'm not as weather towards now I
may need help
I think I may need help just to get out
of bed in the morning and get breakfast
and wash
new plans we'll see patients like June
receive an Urgent Response from a full
service instead of paramedics
and an increase in community-led care
will help to discharge patients quicker
every day over 50 percent of hospital
patients who are ready to go home can't
because of a lack of support it with
Ed's full because the hospital's full
and the hospital's full because the
patients can't get out some of them need
discharge problems huge discharge
problems I definitely support investment
into increased domiciliary care
provision and increased Care Home
provision and increased nursing home
provision because that is what's going
to help hospitals up and down the
country a joint one billion pound
government and NHS program will see
thousands of temporary hospital beds
become permanent and hundreds more
ambulances rolled out
but with one intent NHS posts vacant
Staffing is the key issue absolutely
vital that we grow our Workforce so that
we are able to deliver the Ambitions in
this plan so we're working with the
government on a long-term Workforce plan
for this spring which will be a once in
a generation opportunity to put the NHS
on a sustainable footing June will be
home soon and her sons will do what they
can to care for her but they will need
all the help of a wider Health Service
so she doesn't need to be back in
hospital again
Ashish Joshi Sky News